cool good morning everyone so thank you
very much for coming to my talk docker
has definitely caught everyone's
imagination and everyone's attention and
if definitely changed the way that we
think about how we deploy applications
and how we think about how we get
started and scale up our systems from
something running locally up to
planet-scale systems like Google but
obviously as dock has evolved as a wave
of thinking and it who approaches and
techniques have started to come about
and other technology is a starting form
which have different opinions and
different priorities compared to what
docker provides and fundamentally
containers are Jesse Linux processes so
why do we need docker
at all and this is what I'm gonna be
exploring with you over the next hour so
my name is Ben hall please feel free if
you have any questions or any comments
to contact me via email or Twitter I'm
the founder of a company called cat coda
cat coda is an interactive learning
platform for software developers and we
tell you and help you get started with
cloud native technologies such as docker
kubernetes
container networking
docker security contains security etc
and everything happens directly in your
browser so you don't have to worry about
how to get started you don't have to
worry about installing we'll configure
in anything
instead you can explore and experiment
alongside a fair free interactive
tutorial labs that we have on our
platform and we work with different
companies like Red Hat who have taken
our platform and extended it to help
teach their user base how to deploy
things featured openshift which is their
kubernetes distribution and for today
what I want to start exploring is what
docker provides to the ecosystem and
fundamentally what containers are and
why we can start building and exploring
with different container win times and
different container techniques so we'll
look at what actually happens when we
when dhaka learn what the different
components involved are and we'll look
at how we can move away from needing a
dependency and docker and exploring
other alternatives such as how do we
build container images if we don't have
doc who involved one of the fundamental
principles
and also how do we even processes
without Daka what fundamentally is the
container and finally looking at the
value this brings to an organization so
Before we jump into that let's explore
why this is interesting or why I'm
particularly interested in this topic so
docker has evolved for quite a number of
years if we go way back to when docker
was just being designed and prototyped
this is some of the logos which we could
have ended up with if you go into
99designs and look at the possibilities
and instead of having a nice way or we
could have had a beautiful giraffe and
of the docker since Dan had evolved
we've got to know and love docker with
our container win time it helps us
launch processes in a secure scalable
way helps us deploy applications on both
Linux windows and arm devices in a
consistent experience which is great but
docker itself is also evolving if no
longer just focused on container
launching containers
we've got how do you manage containers
class multiple systems how do you learn
things in a cloud with docker cloud
which had now gone away how do you
compose and orchestrate things they
swarm and compose etc and so docker
itself have evolved into a much bigger
much wider scope project and to the
point where actually docker ie
docker the bit which wins containers
isn't Kodaka anymore
it's called Moby they have renamed a
project to distinguish what the
container runtime is either components
which go in to launch in these processes
in a secure way compared to docker Inc
which is all of datacenter and all of
the more enterprise driven feature sets
and so as cert when we're looking at
running from them very simply I I just
want to win my process in this secure
way there's lots of other moving parts
involved in having documen your stack we
have to take in other dependencies and
youth dock and networking and their
opinions and if we just want to run from
the very lightweight we don't have a
choice we have to go all in but there's
also because of this approach and
because of how doc has structured it's
out it's different for Qt techniques so
docker has a demon the demon is what's
responsible
for managing order containers on your
system all of the processes which are
winning and it basically the gatekeeper
to in your entire host and I said it's a
sensitive part of the system
you should only allow twisted access to
twisted processes and trusted users
could fundamentally you're given on
access to the entire machine but when we
look at how we go through the processes
that are building docket images we need
to give things like Jenkins access to
docker so that they can go through and
they can build our image that can then
get rolled out until you see snippets
like the top one where we learn a
Jenkins agent inside of a container
because everything gets deployed at the
container and we pass in the docker sock
file so this is how our container image
can talk to the parent docker daemon and
use that in order to build these images
and so if we went in we can do things
like duck-billed and it will create our
image but we can also list all of your
depositors on a host and list everything
else winning which is potentially a
security weakness if we don't trust Y
being built inside of our container then
they potentially exploit the system in
very interesting ways but also if we
accidentally have a security breach
for example we accidentally open Jenkins
up to the world which if we do a quick
search on the internet it quite common
then we potentially open up our entire
host to them abilities and being
exploited and being taken advantage of
by Bitcoin miners and other such
malicious actors and so if these kind of
things we're having to structure docker
and have to talk a demon in place
actually makes it more difficult to do
things like build images scale out our
image across multiple systems and
actually have more of a secure system in
place and so this is to read my
alternative container win times have
started and a reason why I'm exploring
how do we use containers and container
images without having docker in the
first place and so if we look at the
alternatives available and this is
contain a landscape probe list by the
cloud computing foundation
see nvf and so cloud native foundation
and so we've got different projects
inside of the foundation so they're
backed and controlled and governed by
the foundation itself ie container D and
locket contain the D is what docker uses
into the covers itself this is how
docker the Feli and their engine and the
daemon talks to the underlying system
and starts our processes it all happened
fire contained D but within the project
spin up from different organizations so
Google last week announced geez Ivor
which is focused on how do you burn a
container with very similar properties
to a virtual machine so you have a
different kernel it wins in it on
isolation space and it's on process
space and so if your application did
have a security weakness and someone did
manage to break out of a container they
wouldn't interact and it wouldn't
interfere and gain access to other
containers renege on your system so
ideal if you're winning quite sensitive
potentially malicious actor and style in
vibrant environment and that's similar
to Intel clear containers again trying
to introduce more of VM like property
into and security model into what
containers can offer and we also now
have kayo which is if you're deploying
cube net is having a container win time
which is design for what kubernetes
needs is designed to solve that problem
and only that problem it doesn't
interact with how do you do in different
systems is how do you walk straight for
different container win times instead of
just delivering the needs that
kubernetes needs and we'll explore more
this later but actually as containers
have evolved we have our ideas have
evolved too and so now you don't even
need to read winning your containers
locally instead you could do something
like the ashore container service and
that could ruin all your feel containers
in the cloud and we could it build per
second you can spin them up do all of
the work loads which you need and then
pair them back down instantly so it
makes ideal for ad-hoc different win
times and being able to take convention
of that within our architecture can open
up some really interesting opportunities
and for me this is where the very starts
to bring when we start breaking our
dependence
and thinking and orchestrating our
system and docker and these kind of
fixed container win times we start
seeing different opportunities which
could exist within our system until we
start thinking about like if we're
winning keeping it is we can have a
container win time which is focused on
the needs of kubernetes
so it's more performing it's more stable
and if more easily maintained by the
open source communities in general which
should deliver a better higher quality
system because everything everyone's
working on that one certain targeted
problem and we build better system and a
better design for continuous
integrations we can focus on how did
that work within a CIPD process and
instead of trying having our container
win time so of 20 different variations
and 20 different problems instead of
just focused on right how do we build
the image in a quickest possible way
because that's the problem which we're
trying to solve and this opens up things
like cloud bursting and being able to
easily win our cow our container build
on something like as your container
instances and so when we start scaling
out we can push the workloads into the
cloud instead of needing to spin up
large virtual machines because we need
that security model in place and these
are the things that we can explore and
the idea is that we can get to something
which looks a little bit more dissipated
and have different container win times
based on what our needs are and so we
could have kubernetes talking to
different container win times so we
could use lib pod which is cryo and if
could win our database it's just winning
a normal container which we win every
day it's it's there and it's happy we
could do something with more higher
security model for more sensitive parts
of our system for example a
public-facing web application it's
exposed to the outside so if it does get
breach because a certain certain
underlying problems or security models
which we haven't realized yet and they
get announced and there are there tax
then they deal wouldn't be able to break
out of that container and I still
wouldn't be able to interact with other
things winning on our cluster and then
because of things like visual containers
if he wanted to have a scale out kind of
like I'm distributing motto which can
scale up and down dynamically and
dramatically based on workloads we could
do things like the turtle Kubler and so
that knows that when we give a container
to learn instead of it winning on our
local docker host instead it will go off
to the indoor container instances and
when the container there and so this
allows us to scale out things like
message handling methods processing or
just scale out how our builds are being
processed and so different builds can
have different characteristics and they
come in at different locations based on
requirements of our system so if we're
going to go down this path and with
we're going to explore how do we do
things without needing docker then what
does dock watch you provide what Adly
happens when we do a docker learn and
launch that contain a process and so in
this case we've got a very simple hello
world application
we're just winning Redis so we do dock
over in Redis so what actually happens
when we execute this command well the
first thing is docker will go off to the
docker hub the docker registry where all
of the public images are stored and it
will go to docker the i/o library which
the user Redis and pull down the latest
image so neither order same default or
we have and we can all avoid deeds if we
wanted to within our system and give
like a targeted version of Redis which
we may want but it'll go off and it will
download the latest version so in this
case it can be read if sweet up 4.0 and
it will pull down the different layers
involved and these this is the docker
image so what is a docker image so if we
look at what goes into creating a sucker
image we it encouraged that document to
start life at the docker file the docker
file is an instead of instructions which
goes into how to configure and how to
learn a particular and how to build a
particular docker image so in this case
we're building a nodejs application
we're defining our dependency at the top
I ain't no tuition 8 so that would go
off and I will use the notation 8 dock
image and then we are extending it
without oh my date
for our application so we're adding
layers on top of that image which will
represent a different configuration
different files which we need for our
application to run for example going off
to the NPM registry to download all of
our dependencies copying of our source
code and then fetching some metadata and
this is where the layer technology and a
layered approach comes in because
fundamentally all we're doing is adding
on extensions to what came before it and
this is what we can explore in a little
bit more detail and so if we go to what
is a image so what I'm going to show you
is what are the fundamental building
blocks about how container images work
and what goes into the details and so if
we come in to enlarge this slightly so
let's go through that example of pulling
down the wettest image so now we're
pulling down two different layers which
went into building of that image and all
of these layers together create another
structure so one layer could be the base
operating system another layer could be
the various binaries and another layer
could be the wettest configuration if we
break it down we can actually explore
what this image is and we can do docker
save give it the name of the image and
we can save it into a tar because
fundamentally all the dock live is a VIP
I tired of directory and so we can
explore and extract that tar file and
you can see that we've got all of the
layers which went in and where we
downloaded we can now explore at the
details of all the files into the covers
and so fundamentally always doing by
doing a docker Paul or docker run it's
dead allowed this tar file and I have it
extracted into the docker data directory
and if we look at what's in this
territory we've got a ha directory we
got some metadata about repositories so
this is saying like what repository
exists and what the version number is
and what's the tag
for that image itself we've got many
first Jason
which gain gives it some more context
and more some more data around how that
image got built and the different layers
involved and for this no disc live talk
all of the information needs to launch
the container win time but fundamentally
at this point always doing is crated to
JSON files which represent which
represent our container and if we look
at something like inside of an image we
can see that it's another file
so the tar containing tar files if we
extract one of those tar files we can
see that if all of the different
components which went in and were built
apart to that layer file and part of
that docker kind of laugh and so if we
go to a tree it go extract it so we can
now look at what's in X CD and we can
see it's got the package manager and
it's got a willed and we can kind of
output and exploit these directories so
fundamentally all we've done is that
docker file what we were doing is
defining the different layers I copying
over the files required into each of
these tar directories and lip in the
mall or tearing them all up into a
single pod the tree and I'm pushing that
into the registry what this means is we
don't really need a docker file to build
this structured image instead we can do
it all manually if we wanted to because
fundamentally it's just a well
structured tar so in this case what
we're doing is towing up an empty
directory and then passing that into
darker import and now we have and give
it the name empty and so now we have the
smallest docket image possible inside
yeah docker image possible and so it's
got all of the metadata which it needs
but if it's empty and so this is the
starting point of every single image but
we can actually build something more
useful based on these techniques and
because all we're doing is creating
these files and we can create an image
I'm using different approaches so in
this case we didn't take busybox busybox
if a very small light weight
distribution Linux distribution ideal
for winning inside containers because it
of it guys super small low footprint and
so in order to kind of like bootstrap
busybox there is that's doing a
different directory easier so we have
this kind of shell script and when we
win it will go off and it will download
bidi box and binaries and install it and
copy into the directory called busybox
and so this is the entire operating
system it's a grand total of 1.9 Meg and
if you actually look at what the
operating system is it's just a single
direct a single binary called bin and if
you list what the bin is all of the
things which we know and love within
Linux
so like Alice dear free make directory
or just get pointed into the single one
binary and fire a symlink
am cord been flashed busy box and so
that's how we've managed to make it so
small and so compact
it's really quite cool i'm so we can
take this and we can build our own i'm
image from it so if we go up and so you
have a pity box so we can add in our own
files so in this case we're adding a
release directory
sorry Oh Alize file I'm called color
code applied to build we want to extend
our image to include that and so just as
we did with creating the empty image
what we can do is zip up that directory
ripple got busy bugs directory as a tar
or toilet are compress our directory
pass it into docker import and so docker
will then convert that tar file into a
docket image for us and so now we can do
ducky images and we have our beautiful
busybox
image created which we convert
and get out our file and so without
needing to create the docker file
without needing to go through the
traditional steps of docker run we can
still get the benefits of having a
docker image created and so by having
this we can explore alternative ways of
building it we don't need to go through
the traditional approaches and we can
use different tools in different
approaches based on what our needs are
ie this can now learn somewhere like the
container actual container infinity's
platform and the reason this is and the
reason this exists is because the
structure which were working with a
creating these towers crater knees
repository chaser and the layers are all
based around an open container spec this
has been created originally by Daka
they were donated to a foundation and so
now anyone involved can create docker
and conclude container images which
congruent on any other container win
time we don't have to be kind of
specified and fixed into ones who don't
have any lock in so we can explore and
go to different approaches and this is
where the whole idea found demoness
builds come in so that we can move and
scale up differently to popular ones at
the moment is one from Red Hat could
builder and a knit one from Jes he works
now at Mike surf previously Google
weather fear docker and she did awesome
work but the idea being is how can we
learn and build our images in a simple
lightweight way which Cole which idea to
the specifications defined so that they
throw in on docker but we convened them
anywhere and we can win them without
needing privileges we don't need a full
video we don't need all of the
permissions which you need instead it
can be something like wait and available
to everyone and the idea is that this
will be compatible with our existing
ways of working so if we come back and
have a quick demo if we look at
it's in some like image and right for
the coder so what we have now is we've
got our container in time our machine
it's got the image binary installed we
can download kind of our dock adoro kind
of like an example directory which I've
got a doc file we can call build on that
and it would look and feel very similar
to what we expect from docker build the
main difference is that we don't have a
dock edemen installed it doesn't have
the dock opposes winning and it doesn't
require an entire virtual machine and
order the permissions from an entire
operating system instead it wins using
rootless technologies and loeb
non-privileged technologies and so we
don't we can burn the builds in a much
more secure way which is ideal when our
builds are slightly more interested and
it will go through it will do everything
which the duck builders I create that
tar file fundamentally and these layers
and then we can push that to a registry
and a work in exactly the same way when
we rolled out across our system so this
is really cool and it's really
interesting waves and directions which
were heading so that's how we can build
an image we can build an image cheese
and different technologies and that can
now give something which we can win so
what happens when we want to run our
process ie Windows or Linux or arm what
happens in the de covers and for the
mentally at this point docker has taken
up fundamental principles which are
available in a kernel
they've packaged them together in a
really nice appropriate way and they've
made it accessible for everyone to build
upon and I what we did today and if you
look at the daka engine and the
different components so we've got our
command line interface a dock of win
that goes off and that talks to the
docker
engine and execute our commands into the
covers the docket engine talks to the
technology hood contained e I
the project looked after by the CNC F
and so completely independent and
available to everyone outside if not
owned and coordinated by docker it's
coordinated by the community and then
that will talk to another technology
could win C and fundamentally win C of
what starts the process in a knife
containerized way and because it went
inside this containerized process it's
winning another container it's secure
and by secure I mean we can add fertile
restrictions about what that process is
or isn't allowed to do so we can
restrict how much memory it's allowed
access to what is the posters here they
can communicate with and see what
devices on the system it's allowed to
access and we can lock it down as much
as possible but fundamentally our
containerized process which da cavern
it's still a running Linux process and
so if we will take our docker in command
for example after that container started
we can list all of the processes on our
system and we see that we've got this
ready server winning it's owned by user
so it's running as a non root user again
low privileged secure by default
mentality and it's got all the pigs and
pulses which you would expect in the
discovers we don't need to use docker
for doing this we could go to win C
launch our container and again that
launcher they're just at this process
winning on our system so what actually
goes into a Linux process what is the
absolute docker doing another covers at
this point so the first thing we need to
know if we want to explore this some
more is we need to identify the pit ie
the process ID of that container so we
can start exploring what's actually
happening in the de covers and so if we
were in docker top give it the container
name it will return the top information
just for that one container and all of
the process is winning in fact that
containerized process and so he gives us
two important IDs one if the pit and one
is the parent pit I which process
started and launch this containerized
process
and so this case appeared I'm the
process of that very server in three
five three seven and so now we can
explore them what's happening like how
is that configured and so all the
processes on Linux live in a directory
called proc pork is the heart of all the
Linux processes and as all of the
information about everything on our
system and so if you lift the contents
of pork you'll see things like 1 10 11
ie all of posis IDs which are winning on
our system so one being v empty or the
innate system and now also all of the
other things like our container which is
winning and if we go into that directory
we'll see lots of file with with strange
random names but they all have a certain
targeted purpose and so we connect start
exploring these so for example if we
look at the XE directory the or kind of
file the XE file is a pointer to the
process which have been launched and so
we can find out the end-of-line process
at that pot that page is related to so
in this case the ready server we can
look at the command line I what command
line with used in order to launch this
process we thought from top it was to
read a server and a port number and we
can also start exploring things like the
environment variables so what
environments are set on this process the
reason if is interesting is because we
can start changing my and modifying me
files these are just standard Linux
principles and so when we do a doc verne
we patent an environment variable flag
like a a hostname or color like a
password that password is actually
defined within this file and when
possess winning it's configured and
asked what environment variables dobry
am i aware of the contents of this file
if what and the process has access to
but this is also how all of the security
models within that containerized process
are configured and so one of the
examples of how a container is actually
contained or how a container processes
as it contains if you think control
groups a fee groups
and three groups restrict how much of a
resource the process is allowed to
access so for example it will control
how much memory that process is allowed
to utilize and that value is a file
stored on disk with in the process
directory and so in this case what we're
doing is we're looking at the CPU shares
at a how much CPU is that process
allowed but we're also modifying the
memory usage within up that process had
allowed to access and so we're occurring
eight thousand or eight million into the
file called memory dot limit in bytes
Linux and that covers we'll happy
convert that into the proper value and
not that eight thousand it would convert
it into actually the bytes correct byte
value but now if we look at the stats
and the information by that container we
can see that the process has been
limited and we change that we increase
it we can see that value increase
alongside and so we can start changing
and modifying the security models of any
process within our system whether it
been started by dark or not and if you
phenomenally how people like Google and
Heroku and all of the other technologies
were able to run processes in a secure
container way before docker existed and
how doc Reggie gets it security model
and so the another technique if
namespaces again namespaces are just
references and pointers on disk and so
we can explore it can navigate and see
what namespaces are processes attached
to and I would how that for quixote
model it applied so the mounts the pid'
namespace and net namespace and how we
can ensure that that process have a
different theater different entry point
and view of the system than anything
else winning our system the namespaces
allow us to limit and segregate each
process so that they can't communicate
with each other ensure that they get
different path trees until we list the
container they only feed what processes
that container and she had access to and
that's all done by the namespace
and then final key aspect of docket
security and what makes a container
contained or process contains are three
techniques a Parma set comp and
capabilities at armor it the first one
which we see so we can look at any
profile was have been find which had
been fine to a process and in this case
we got the app armor profile darker
default enforced and so this means that
the app armor profile had been applied
the profile would basically define angle
if it's moves and what opposes can or
cannot do and so you can define a wall
saying I processes allowed to send TCP
packets but it's not allowed to send
Ward network packets II's not allowed to
send ping commands to the outside world
or it's allowed to write to the opt
dietary but it's not allowed to watch
being XE home etc and this profile is
was is designed to represent what a
normal functioning application is meant
to be able to do and if the application
goes outside of this then it's not
functioning that it's not allowed and if
we strict it and I divining this secure
profile the next technique is set comp
so ii is similar but it's designed to
restrict which system cause a process
either allowed isn't allowed to make so
with in linux everything that an
application does fundamentally gets
boiled down to three hundred and
thirty-some same system cause and for
the system cause that seems like opening
a file changing modifications checking
if it's got access to read clothing file
pointer handles fermented their
underlying primitives of everything now
mostly 15 calls are happy and kind of
faithful processes to call other ones
are a little bit more sensitive they
they allow positives to install kernel
modules or they allow them to mount
additional discs
install additional network devices etc
which are a lot more sensitive and
thumbs in which we wouldn't want posters
potentially to
access to and supply even that comp we
can restrict what processor what this
and cause that process is allowed to
make and for this is how we can start
enforcing a better security model and
finally we can look at the capabilities
now capability their groupings of
security techniques a grouping of
functionalities that are that exist
within Linux so for example can I change
the system time is a capability and then
you can define whether the process is
oil isn't allowed to do that capability
ie is it allowed to change the system
time or not and there's many different
capabilities and they're all stored in a
interesting bit mask and if we decode
that bit bit mask we can see all of the
processes and everything well that
container is or isn't allowed to do and
because all of the primitives that we
have are indeed wall containers it means
that in order to launch a process in a
different security model all we need to
do is know how D processes the file the
put together and how to correctly change
them and when we need you and this is
how we've got different container win
times which have emerged to the point
where if we wanted to create our own
container win time we could do though in
roughly 23 lines of code so this is an
example from Liz Weiss
she's a developer evangelist at aqua
security and she uses go in order to
create the most foundation simple
lightweight container in time possible
and we can see that actually if we go
through it line by line we can see that
aids launching a process in a different
security model than normal in a more
restrictive security model and so it's
configuring the fee groups I what how
much resources is if process which is
gonna be launched allowed to access its
setting some paid limits so they can how
many processes is that process allowed
to fork and launch and it covers it sets
in safe amount directories
so it can get access to certain
properties if changing the route the to
route so instead of having access to
everything on our desk it only had
access to a certain directory i dis is
how docker changed it the root of the
container to point to that docker image
directory and that's how the container
processes work and if these kind of
techniques which allow us to launch and
use different containers in times so if
we have a look at how do we launch a
container I'd contains process we can
look at something like Putman actually
let's do what is a container so what
we're going to do is we can run like our
contain process just to see some of the
techniques and it covers so we can get
the pit limits or the pit ID which is
one one thinks one in this case we can
see the process 3 of that like what went
into a kilo engineer so this is the
process it was launched by docker
container D and which was launched
eventually by dr. D and so we can see
how that process went in to being
launched and now because everything's in
that pot directory we can explore we can
we can feel the files we can explore
them a what environment variables have I
been defined etc so we have these names
races which get attached so if we look
at trees a cat net
so we have all of our the net the
network interface network component etc
and what we can do is we can launch view
the network namespaces I thought trying
to go for and we can launch processes
attached to these namespaces which can
be shared and so we can do PS and so now
what we're doing if you didn't share
which is the technique of launching a
process which have been attached to
either containerized processes and for
in this case we use an ensure we're
telling it to launch a new process we're
telling it to have a separate paid
namespace talent directory so it knows
how to launch an N launch bash and
fundamentally that is kind of a
contained process it's been in it filmed
in space it can't access anything else
within our system and that inter
fundamental starting point to how we can
launch these processes in a secure
container wised way and if these
attorneys would go in to building our
container than what dock without you
doing with C groups up armor and
capabilities that's why I wanted to show
some what about either container win
times so if we have a look Padma
so what Putman is doing is taking all of
these primitives of what's available
within three groups and building them
into an alternative container win time
the main difference is if we don't need
anything installed on our system apart
from the pod man CLI itself and when C
and we don't need a daemon running to
manage the processor instead the
processes are just winning in this
container odds way by taking the
techniques of configuring lessee groups
and configuring these capabilities so if
we do pipeline when we can give it the
same docket image because phenomena
docker image is a container image based
on a spec and so it can burn anywhere
all we need to do download and extract
that tar file and we can launch a
process because fundamentally all the
process is is a Linux with different
cgroups namespaces and the prot
directory configurations defined so
anyone is able to do this ie Padma and
all if there is the CLI is a wrapper
over the top of these processes which
are winning on our system so in this
case it will list all of the processes
running which have been started by
apartment but if we look at the process
tree if we do P X P s3 see how good my
memory is the process tree it's a lot
smaller and a lot more focused than what
it was before because we don't have
these demons hanging around which are
controlling that application and so now
we we don't have to worry about what
happens if the demon crashes because
it's not going to kill all the positives
which it launched because there is no
demon process in its place it's just the
same as if we just ran PS or kind of
like any other process on our system pod
mine is just winning a process and
configuring a security model around it
making it a very lightweight those
streamlined way to launch processes on
any system and this is the idea we have
with different container win times we
want to take it to the bear to the bear
principals once we have that in place we
can start exploring different security
models and so this is where we start
seeing things
I know twin ative container win times
start popping up like catch containers
or Windows hyper-v containers they just
take that process they can launch it
within a very cut-down very lightweight
streamlined virtual machine so that you
get a different kernel that you're not
showing the same kernel you get more
secure bounty contacts and I search if I
process does get broken into and
exploited if they do manage to break out
the containers they don't have access to
everything else on our system so again
why is this important so this becomes
critical where we look at things like
Cuba Nettie's Cuba noted itself is a
container orchestration if designed to
learn manage and control all of the
processes across our deployments and
Cuba natives is great it's been building
on top of docker and they've taken
advantage of all of these container
technologies the problem becomes when
docker want to go down a certain path
and a vision and how they want that API
to be structured which is particularly
not aligned with the vision of how Cuba
Nettie's wants things to be winning so
for example if you have ever including
it is and you've looked at what winning
you'll see lots of pores processes
winning and if Paul's processes is
because Cuba natives talk to their
within around a pod concept of a pod
where you can share network interfaces
the volumes and different security
aspects of a container together thinking
multiple containers which can all act as
if two on the same machine but docker
doesn't have this concept of a pod so
they've kind of had to you create kind
of these abstractions to represent how
they want to Burnett is to be structured
in an ideal world so instead of that
they're going down a different path and
allowing support for different container
win times one of which it would you cryo
which he designed with kubernetes in
mind and designed to be aligned with how
connected that's operating and keep it a
small lightweight and streamlined and so
that when kubernetes is upgrading and
making changes cryo is there to support
it and it works almost in exactly the
same way but it's a little bit easier
for the community and operators to
manage and so we look at and getting
started so if we do kubernetes init
large so to baby Emma nipped so Cupid
eme it's a way to bootstrap a keeping in
touch Calista and so what it will do is
go through and set up things like
certificates and so that all it's a
different committee Cuban exit processes
can talk to each other set up all of the
different configuration download all of
the container images required in order
to launcher and so but for this will go
to darker and I'll do everything via the
docker API but now we've started having
these abstractions and supporting
different container win times I cut a
container of G's either docker and cryo
and so when we do it what we do is we
pointed to a different container
one-time interface ie in this case cryo
socket file and so now instead of cuvee
diem and kubernetes initializing itself
on top of docker initial I did itself
using this process and so if we create
this if we look at docker PS we don't
have any containers winning if we do
kubernetes win time interface controlled
PS we can see all of these processes
which are Venant
and compared to what it looks like when
we do kubernetes and docker which is
lots of pores containers lots more noise
instead we have a much more focused
experience we can see the processes that
kubernetes requires either api the
control manager the scheduler so that
these things can be launched and it's
much more focused on how the kubernetes
experience is designed home and so these
were launched and we can interact and
control and feed positive and exactly
the same way as we would
before including that is is being open
and transparent to supporting these
different container win times so if you
look we've got our master winning we can
describe the master and get the
container win time version and so now
they will support and be open to
different platforms based on what our
needs are which will decide and for
example what does this mean so what it
means is when we look at things like the
azure contain instances we want the
ability for Cuba natives to be able to
schedule different types of workloads be
that doctor containers been in our hosts
container win times in that secure more
containerized sandbox to everything like
cattle containers and hyper-v containers
they also allowed to scale up to things
like as your container instances and
tomato if easier Microsoft have built
something called the virtual Kubler and
so what we can do is we have our
different kubernetes nodes within our
system they know how to launch
containers I'm according to the
different container win times that we
specified and the different security
techniques that we require but the
virtual Kubler also knows how to launch
containers and different systems one of
which is thieves or container container
infinitive service and so if we wanted
to scale up we can have the virtual cube
let go off to the API deploy the process
their workloads happens and then when
it's finished it gets head back down
again and so by thinking differently and
thinking beyond the scope of why we have
docker and we have processes and if
you've have we launched things we can
change how our architecture happened
within our system and as such we can
start exploring new alternative ways of
deploying and managing our system and so
the demos which I show to you are all
available online if good catch Khoda
I've got demos and scenarios which walk
you through what a container a process
is which I showed you and explore today
how to build images and how to get
started and for me I find it's really
interesting because it allows us to
build systems that are appropriate for
our needs
it allows it to build systems I designed
to
so particular problems like all I need
to do is build container images in a
secure way so instead of having to worry
about the entire the docker stack
instead I can just use image and a
command line tool which will go ahead
and build up one image process for me
and allow me to win it anywhere because
we don't need the security model of
winning an entire containerized system
and if you also take things like cloud
bursting builds which I think are gonna
be a great advantage in the future and
so that we don't need to have these big
heavy virtual machines hanging around
instead we can just have processors
winning and within the civilus
foundations and several technologies
we'll see more this happening over the
future and more this coming but at the
moment today we have things like cryo
we have pod man so that we can learn
these processes in a containerized way
and we have different ways of building
to build our images and more coming soon
and particularly from google so hope you
found that interesting it's an insight
into what's coming into the future and
how I think the landscape is changing if
you have any questions then please do
email me or tweet me and with that I
hope you enjoy the rest of your
conference thank you